to arbitrary detention
but for now to nazanin and anushay i am
pleased that in just a few hours time we
will be able to say welcome home
i commend this statement to the house
senate foreign secretary david lamey
well mr speaker i thank the foreign
secretary for advanced site of the
statement mr speaker for too long the
iranian government have been depriving
british nationals of their liberty to
use them as political bargaining ships
nazideen zadari radcliffe has been
detained in iran for almost six years
anushay ashuri has faced the same fate
for almost five years the suffering they
have endured during these years is
unimaginable the moments of laughter joy
and hope that they and their families
have lost are irretrievable the iranian
government is entirely to blame for
these acts of cruelty
the whole house will be overjoyed that
their detention has now come to an end
and that nazimen and ashuri can return
to british soil to be reunited with
their families to take the breath of
freedom once again we must pay tribute
to their tireless families who showed
extraordinary strength resilience and
courage in the face of unimaginable
ordeal
i also give credit to the member for
hampstead and kilburn
for all of her efforts over so many
years and to the member for lewisham
east for continuing to raise these
issues for their tireless work in
campaigning to secure the freedom of
their constituents we join the
government in thanking
the government of oman for their help
i also give credit to the tireless work
of british officials as well as the
foreign secretary for her role in
securing justice
she sowed more skills in diplomacy than
her bungling boss who appeared to do
more damage than help while he held her
current post
there are serious lessons
that need to be learned from this
appalling episode we need stronger
international measures to combat the use
of arbitrary detention as a political
tool
to end hostage diplomacy and we need a
review of these cases we need to
understand what could have been done by
the british government to secure
releases sooner i note that the foreign
secretary says she stepped up these
efforts over the last six months and i
give her credit for that we welcome that
but we asked what efforts were not taken
by her predecessors that could have been
a review must also consider what
comments made by ministers indeed
contributed to extended detention
it's also good news that morad tabas had
been released on furlough could the
foreign secretary elaborate on the next
steps to support his case we note that
there remain other british nationals
still in detention seeking help from the
british government can the foreign
secretary update the house on the latest
number and what efforts is in place to
help them mr speaker we welcome the
government's parallel announcement that
the imet debt has been repaid we have
long called for the government to find a
way to pay back that internationally
recognized and legitimate debt
what guarantees have the government been
given that the sum
will only be used for humanitarian
purposes today though let us focus on
the main point of this statement the
whole house and the whole country
can share in the triumph of welcoming
nazardeen and anushay home
for a secretary
there have been years of efforts and
some fantastic people
in the foreign office including leaders
of the foreign office in the foreign
office team who have worked tirelessly
what has changed in the last six months
is we do have a new government in iran
and i was able when i went to new york
in september and met minister abdullah
to reset the relationship and be clear
that we were serious about resolving the
outstanding issues that iran had and
they were clear they were serious about
resolving the outstanding issues we had
and i do want to pay tribute to the
fantastic foreign office officials who
have been absolutely tenacious in
traveling to tehran and getting this
done in what is a very difficult
circumstance because as the right
honourable gentleman is aware
paying money to iran
with the intensive sanctions raising in
place is not easy even though this is
very clearly a legitimate debt and i can
completely assure him that we do have
humanitarian guarantees what i can't do
is go into the details because that is
confidential between the parties but i
have had this thoroughly checked out
across government to ensure that we have
those guarantees that it will be used
for humanitarian purposes on the subject
of murad tabaz who i spoke to at the end
of last year when he was in prison here
we have secured release for him on
furlough so he is now at home and that
was a very important point we were
pressing with the iranian government i
know from speaking to him that the
conditions in prison were absolutely
abhorrent and appalling so he is now in
better conditions but of course we will
continue to work to get him home
as well as other detainees who do not
want then and names released in public
the other point i'd make about mr tabaz
is of course he is a tri-national with
the us uh so we do need to work with our
u.s partners on this issue and we are
talking to him but in the spirit of uh
what what he said about welcoming the
families home that should really be our
focus today they have been through an
appalling ordeal
i can't imagine what it is like to be
without my family my my mother for so
long and we must give the families the
privacy uh they deserve and we must
thank them for their tenacity through
this appalling ordeal that should never
happen to anyone
committed to a gun
mr speaker um i'm
hugely grateful for the extraordinarily
welcome news that my writing friend has
brought to the house this afternoon it
is the most
wonderful uh
moment for many of us who've been
campaigning but particularly and i pay
huge tribute for the two honourable
members opposite for hamster and kilburn
and for lewisham east but also
for our friend anne clewett who spent an
awful lot of time campaigning for this
as well when she was in this house
may i ask
whether or not the government has been
looking at some of the implications that
happened when the last time uh a ransom
payment was paid to the iranian
government and that ransom payment was
paid by the u.s government a number of
years ago about six months after they
were paid
the iranian government took another six
american dual nationals hostage and
merely started the whole process
again sadly furthermore the money that
was paid was then spent on murdering
hundreds of thousands of sunni muslims
in syria can she assure us that that
will not happen this time that british
citizens will be very carefully warned
of the dangers they face in visiting
iran and that none of this payment will
end up in weapons and ammunition to kill
syrians
well first it's very important to note
that these are two parallel issues in
our bilateral relationship namely
settling the ims debt which is a
legitimate debt that the uk government
were due to pay
as well as settling the issue of the
detainees i am very clear
that we need to work with our
international pr partners to end the
practice of arbitrary detention in fact
we are joining a group with the
canadians and others to do just that so
we have a strong
international response to the practice
of arbitrary detention being used by
countries
to
get their own way so i completely agree
with my honourable friend we need to end
this practice we need to end this
practice working with partners it's a
key point that we're discussing as part
of the g7 foreign minister's track
snp spokesperson alan smith
thank you mr speaker i'd also thank the
foreign secretary for citing the
statement and uh goodness in a week when
we could all be doing with a bit of good
news i was very glad to read it
the snp shares the happiness at the
release of nazareth cliff anushi ashuri
and murad takbad we'd also pay tribute
to their friends and their families and
themselves for putting up with an
intolerable situation
and this has been a long time coming and
i think there are lessons to learn but i
think the foreign secretary her
ministers and officials deserve their
moment on this this has been a great
achievement and i'm very glad to see
that happen
and the news that the historic debt is
going to be paid as humanitarian aid
well i proposed that from this place on
the 16th of november 2021 so i can
hardly quibble that it's happened i'm
glad of the assurances that it will go
to humanitarian purposes and i'll take
that on trust which i think we're all
entitled to do but i've got two
questions the the first is how many
jewel nationals are in iran in this
situation because we're aware there's
some but we don't know how many
specifically there are and also what
wider assessment there are of other dual
nationals in this position elsewhere and
also the concerns of the chair of the
foreign affairs committee that uh there
is a risk of moral hazard in this uh
where i think we all agreed that this is
historic debt that needed to be repaid
others could take other lessons from
this
and what what assessment has been made
of the risk of moral hazard to people
british citizens going to iran but also
in other places of risk and perhaps the
foreign office guidance needs to be
updated in those situations i'd be
grateful for an update on that as well
but congratulations thank you
well on the on the honourable
gentleman's first point i'm afraid i
can't comment on individual cases
and even to the extent of talking about
the numbers of individual cases i'm
afraid i can't do that
the honourable gentleman is right that
we do need to work against arbitrary
detention the best way to do that
is part of an international compact
that's why we're addressing this issue
at the g7 that's why i welcome the
canadians leadership on the issue and
i've met my canadian counterpart on
several occasions and talked about how
we move this forward to change the
incentives you know what we need to do
is fundamentally change the incentives
for governments so there is not an
incentive to behave in this way
jeremy hell
can i salute the leadership of the
foreign secretary on this issue as i
know from my own experience this is a
fearsomely difficult diplomatic
challenge and it wouldn't have been
solved without sustained personal
interest right from the top and she
deserves great credit for that
can i most of all though commend the
efforts of richard radcliffe nazinen's
his quiet courage
his humility
his total determination never wavered
throughout six years of hell and i think
he was really the bravest person i met
during my time as foreign secretary an
inspiration to many people and can i ask
the foreign secretary
is she inspired by the
united western response to the crisis in
ukraine
and is there something we can learn from
that to unite as democratic countries to
stamp out the vile practice of
hostage-taking
my right honourable friend is absolutely
right about richard ratcliffe
and the families of the detainees and
the courage that they've shown in the
face of appalling adversity as well as
those detained themselves who've really
gone through
incredible hardship
and difficulty and just not knowing uh
what the future would look like and i
pay tribute to the work my right
honourable friend did when he was
foreign secretary and the leadership he
has also shown
in in his current role
on this issue he is completely right you
know this is
why we are working with allies like the
canadians on the issue of unfair
detention because we need to take a
common stance and the way we have worked
together on ukraine on sanctions
on supplying defensive aid to
to ukraine shows that we can do this in
other areas and really stand up for
freedom and democracy and the
rules-based international order and
change the fundamental
incentives
that regimes like this have in terms of
the way they behave
thank you
thank you mr speaker mr speaker this is
really a day of celebration for the
anushay family and i think they will be
so relieved when the plane hits the
ground
and uh both nazaneen and ashuri are
walking again on british soil
um and as a new shade member of
parliament i am of course thrilled
beyond belief for his release and
vanessa name and i'm incredibly happy
for anushay's wife sherry for his
children elika and ariane as well as for
their families and friends and today i
spoke to sherry indeed i've been
speaking to her
yesterday as well and
she tells me that she has had several
years of heartache and separation
and of course all of this could have
been avoided
it is right that the issue of the
long-standing debt of approximately 400
million pounds was addressed and
returned by the british government to
secure the freedom of our british
citizens and i i do salute as well the
foreign secretary for making the ims
debt her priority and i thank her for
that but i would also
like to say that it has been over 1
650 days since anushay was detained and
these are days of his life that cannot
be returned to him
i would therefore like to ask the right
honourable member why it has taken so
long for the government to secure
nazanin and anushay's release
well i'd like to pay tribute to the
honorable lady for her tireless
campaigning uh on this issue and i share
her sense of anxiety and there were some
very anxious moments this afternoon as
we waited for wheels up
in tehran as the plane departed and we
knew that finally
our detainees and nazanin and nushay
would be returning back to the united
kingdom and we're very much looking
forward to welcoming them uh later on
today and i too have spoken to the
family to sherry and i know how hard it
has been for the families and you know
the courage that they have shown uh over
these very very difficult years
what i will say about the process of
securing
uh the release of our detainees is the
foreign secretaries
the prime minister foreign office
officials have worked tirelessly on this
you know there really is a very very
dedicated team at the foreign office
last summer we saw a new government in
place in iran it did give us an
opportunity to
start afresh on some of these issues to
look at new ways we could do things in
terms of paying
the ims debt and we have been able to
deliver on this but we have to remember
that fundamentally it was the iranian
government who put these people in
detention and ultimately what we need to
do as many members across this house
have been saying is change the
incentives on government so taking
detainees unfairly is not seen
as something that is a proposition uh in
the modern world but i do pay tribute to
foreign office officials who have worked
tirelessly for years to make this happen
thank you mr speaker the daughter of
murad tabaz is my constituent and i
would like to pay tribute to the foreign
secretary and her team for all of her
efforts can my right honorable friend
assure me that she and her team will
continue to work with the us
in order to ensure that he may leave
iran and can she tell me practically
what being on furlough from prison
entails
and i have spoken today
uh it is a very very uh difficult
situation maura tabas is of course a
tri-national
u.s uk
and
iranian and the iranian government do
treat him as being a u.s national as
well as a
uk national we push very hard to get
morad out of prison and i spoke to him
when in when he was in prison and he was
in appalling conditions i'm pleased to
say
that i have been in touch today and he
is now
back at his house
uh with with security
in place but he is back at his house
with his family in tehran now we will
continue to work
to get him back home and we will be
working with our allies including the
united states
to make that happen but i am pleased
that we have been able uh to secure his
release from prison and return home in
tehran
lebron
thank you mr speaker
i think we've all been quite emotional
today um tears of joy i hope are going
to be cried this evening and to think
that
richard ratcliffe will be able to
welcome nazanin and she might even put
gabriella to bed or even take her to
school tomorrow for the first
time what a thought
the 400 million pounds that has been
paid as the legitimate debt we've been
told for a long time was not linked
well i'm glad that it's been paid and
i'm glad that in any way it's led to
their release what i asked the foreign
secretary is that's not an insignificant
sum in the context of voter spend
can she assure
that there wouldn't this not going to
count towards our own spend and comes
over on top of other planned spending
well i can assure the honourable lady
that this comes from the ministry of
defense so the ministry of defense it's
a long-standing debt
uh that the ministry of defence have
have paid uh in accordance with uh the
international rules including ensuring
that this money is going to be spent on
humanitarian purposes and
i am
you know pleased that
richard and gabriella who are in the
gallery today
will be able to see
uh see nazanin again this evening and i
pay tribute to richard
and gabriela for their fortitude in such
appalling appalling circumstances
mr speaker
at a time when every day we're reminded
of the amazing resilience of a country
this is a great moment
to be reminded of the resilience of
individuals and families and the
particular families the detainees who
are coming back this evening what an
amazing achievement by everybody
involved i think it'd be fair to also
thank the iranians the new iranian
government for their role in this
as well
could my right honourable friend confirm
whether there are any lessons that we
need to learn about dual nationals and
advice given to them in traveling not
just to iran but to other countries
and could she also confirm
whether the agreement that she's reached
with her iranian counterpart provides
some form of pathway for other
british detainees in iran eventually to
return to
well of course we will you know look to
make sure that our travel advice and we
always make sure our travel advice
is as good as possible and when i met my
iranian counterpart uh in september
i was very clear that there are key
bilateral issues that we needed to
resolve namely the detainee issue also
the ims issue and of course we don't
agree with iran on many topics you know
we're not naive
about the situation in iran but we need
to absolutely make sure we're protecting
our british nationals that is my top
priority and that is what i will
continue to work to do
true liberty
mr speaker after six years i can mention
azelene zagari ratcliffe in the chamber
and not beg for her release so thank you
mr speaker after eight urgent questions
and countless debates it's a pleasure to
finally be standing here and talking
about her and this wouldn't have
happened without the foreign secretary
and the member for braintree so can i
say thank you from the bottom of my
heart and to all the fco officials who i
know worked tirelessly to make this
happen so thank you
i also wanted to thank redress gibson
dunn change uk and amnesty international
and other organizations and individuals
who worked so hard to release nasaline
and can i thank all the mps on behalf of
richard radcliff who texted me just
before i stood up to say thank you
across the chamber because whichever
side of the house you were in you worked
hard
everyone worked hard to make sure that
nasalin was released so whichever party
whichever member wherever whichever
constituency you represented thank you
and thank you from richard radcliff as
well including all the mps who visited
richard when he was on both his hunger
strikes
and to the community especially in west
hampstead where naslin's home is thank
you for always coming and supporting us
but most importantly i want to pay
tribute to my constituent richard
radcliffe
for his relentless campaigning but i
also think he's really set the bar high
for all husbands
can i say
[Laughter]
can i say
to nazanin welcome home after six long
years and can i say to gabriella
this time mommy really is coming home
now finish by asking the foreign
secretary who i am very very grateful to
once again could she update us a bit
more on why maura tabas wasn't allowed
to leave iran he actually lived in my
constituency as well when he was in the
uk so i'd like to hear an update on that
[Applause]
well can i can i thank the honourable
lady for her tireless campaigning and
also her patience
in the last 24 hours she and i have had
a number of conversations and it was
only when we heard
that the wheels were up in tehran that
we really knew it was happening and you
know i was just extremely concerned to
make sure
that
nazanin and nushay had really been able
to leave iran and i'm so delighted that
we are going to be able to welcome them
home today and the family
is going to be able to welcome them home
today and she is absolutely right about
richard and gabriella and the other
families who campaigned so tirelessly
and
it's it's been an incredibly an
incredibly difficult time and she's also
right to pay tribute to my honourable
friend the middle the minister for the i
mean he's now minister for the middle
east europe russia
because he's so talented and gets so
much done but you know my humble friend
has held countless meetings as well uh
to make sure this happens it's not been
a uh an easy easy process on the subject
of murad tabaz the the real issue is
that he is a tri-national and that is
seen in iranian eyes as also
meaning that the us are involved and we
are working very closely with the u.s we
have secured his release from prison of
course we want to see him uh come home
and we will continue to work to achieve
that with our u.s partners
thank you mr speaker may i congratulate
my right honorable friend and indeed all
the team at the foreign office of the
legal team who i know will have worked
extremely hard into everybody including
honourable members for their tireless
work can
my right honourable friend assure me
that in our adherence to the
international rules-based system by
paying the debt that it was a judge we
owed to iran we shall not swaver from
our belief that the arbitrary detention
of nationals or whatever
country is wrong
and that we must redouble our efforts if
we are to effectively defend
the international rules based system
that she and i know is under
unprecedented attack
my honourable friend is right that
arbitrary detention is completely wrong
we are stepping up our efforts together
with our g7 colleagues to work more
closely together to challenge uh that
type of behavior internationally and i
think over the uh ukraine
crisis and the abhorrent invasion of
ukraine by russia you have seen
the international community step up and
democratic nations work together and we
are determined to
address all of those issues including
the issue of arbitrary detention
we know comes the person who mentioned
every thursday val rivers
thank you mr speaker can i start by
thanking the foreign secretary for all
her work and her minister who answered
all the urgent questions and all the
officials at the fcdo throughout the six
years i know my uh my honourable friends
the members for hamster and kilburn and
newsham east
are delighted to get their constituents
back but none more so than the radcliffe
family the wider rattler family who we
all met on richard's hunger strike and
and anushay's family uh they're pleased
to get them back and murad tabaz
actually his birth certificate which
i've seen was born in hammersmith so i
hope we can make extra efforts but i'd
like to ask
the foreign secretary if she will ensure
that maran grove even though he may not
have asked for help that he's not
forgotten
but mr speaker this was house business
and the house is delighted that nazanin
and anushay are back in the loving arms
of their family
well thank you and
i can assure the honourable lady that
every single british national who is
unfairly detained overseas
is on our minds and we are working to
see them released
catherine fletcher
mr speaker and i the foreign secretary
has rightly received many plaudits for
the work that her and her teams have
done and the people of south level have
been writing to me since i was first
elected in 2019 urging her and her team
to strain every sinew in difficult
circumstances it's not often that they
can all go home from work putting that
smile of that little girl's face so will
she join with me and saying thank you
from south ribble and to the for their
efforts
well this this has been a team effort
and
as we've said we've seen incredible
fortitude and stoicism from the families
from
those detained in iran themselves and of
course all of our constituents who are
so deeply concerned about the terrible
plight
that nazanin and her family have faced
sami wilson
and can i also add my congratulations to
the foreign secretary for her tenacity
and determination
in resolving uh these particular issues
i hope she shows the same tenacious
determination in resolving the issues
which affect northern ireland as well uh
in her negotiations um but
i i'm sure
i don't know i didn't know the families
i met i met nazanin's husband once
outside the foreign office when he was
conducting his hunger strike and he told
me of the ups and downs
and the hopes being raised and dashed um
continually and i'm sure that
this the the work which the minister has
done and her officials has given great
help
to the families who now have their loved
ones released and hope to those who
still are looking forward to having
their families released i know that the
minister had to link these two things
together but has she any concerns that
linking the payment of money to the
release of these hostages might send out
the wrong
signal to criminal regimes across the
world who have no hesitation in using
humans in this way
well to answer the honourable
gentleman's first point i will not give
up until i have fixed the northern
ireland protocol i can absolutely assure
him uh i can assure him of that
and
these issues that are long-standing
issues with iran have been treated in
parallel i have been very clear the
government has been very clear that this
is legitimate debt that the uk
government should pay and that is right
and that is what we have done and we
have found a way of doing that despite
uh the various sanctions regimes are in
place and we have made sure that it is
spent
on humanitarian support
phil clark
mr speaker it is excellent news that
three british nationals have been
released from iranian prisons today
i met richard ratcliffe's nazaneen's
husband several years ago at a reception
hosted by you mr speaker in this place
to hear directly of her plight and
detention so i'm delighted that she has
finally been released is on her way home
so can i firstly congratulate my
honorable friend for all her work but
also ask her to confirm that her
department will continue to support
other british nationals in iran who have
also asked for our help
we will continue to support british
nationals in iran and all of the
families have been provided with
consular support support from our
officials and i'm very proud of the
uh support that they have offered but of
course we will continue to work to make
sure
that those unfairly detained are able to
return home
jeremy corbyn
mr speaker this is brilliant and
excellent news and i thank the foreign
secretary for the statement she's made
today and congratulate the members for
lewisham and hampton and kilburn for the
work they put in could she give us
any indication of when she expects
merito bars to actually be released
because being on furlough is not a very
satisfactory situation obviously he has
the right to return to this country as
as do others she mentioned that she
can't name all the dual nationals of
british nationals being held and i
understand that but one in particular
marine roof a labour rights activist has
been clearly publicly named by amnesty
international and redress
and
is on apparently a long-term prison
sentence could you tell us what efforts
being made to secure his release and
also in this
change relationship we now have with
iran which is welcome
will there now be a robust human rights
dialogue with iran because
detention of foreign nationals is
appalling but also there are many other
human rights issues that deserve and
must be raised with iran and i hope this
will be the start of a serious dialogue
which hopefully will improve the human
rights of everybody
well on the on the subject of the
individual that the honorable gentleman
names i do have to respect the
individual's request of whether or not
their case should be raised in public
and
that is why
we only mention publicly
those individuals who've asked to be
named but of course
we continue to supply support to all
british nationals who have been
unfairly detained and
as i said previously there are many
issues over which we do not have
agreement with iran but i will continue
to talk uh to the iranian foreign
minister and work with the iranian
foreign minister to make sure we do
resolve issues between us that pertain
to the british national interest dr
andrew morrison this news is like
sunshine on a rainy day congratulations
to all involved would you agree with me
that particular tribute needs to be made
to
say badir and the omani government who
are establishing themselves as
interlocutors and mediators par
excellence in the region and would she
say what assurances she has got that the
irgc will simply not replace
nazine anusha murad with other dual
nationals and will she reiterate her
warnings to dual nationals who may fall
within the iranian jurisdiction and that
they should tread very carefully indeed
minister bader and the omani government
have been incredibly helpful
in assisting us with
this issue and i want to pay tribute
they
they flew
the detainees out
to muscat
i've been in regular touch with minister
bader since i first met him uh in
december last year and they have been
instrumental in making their that happen
and they are true friends uh of the
united kingdom
the honourable gentleman is writing what
he says about dual nationals but
fundamentally we need to change the
incentives on the system so people can
travel freely without fear of unfair
detainment
hillary
thank you very much indeed mr speaker
may i join other members in thanking
the foreign secretary her officials my
two honorable friends and everyone who
has brought this wonderful
day to pass made all the sweeter by the
smiles that we see looking down on us
from the gallery
the foreign secretary said that the debt
was paid in
parallel but we all know that for the
government of iran it was always
sequential
and given what she said about the work
she's doing with other g7 members
including canada
to try and deal with this what practical
steps
is she hoping to secure through this to
ensure that in future it is much much
more difficult for governments to engage
in hostage-taking
for political purposes
the right honorable gentleman
is right that we do need to
change the practice of
countries detaining
other countries nationally
nationals unfairly and that is precisely
what we are working on with our canadian
counterparts and others but we need to
act in concert to change the system
and change the reactions uh that we give
overall but i can't say more at this
stage but i hope to be able to say more
soon
jeremy wright thank you very much mr
speaker this is a day of great joy and
relief not just for those flying home
today but also for their families some
of whom it's wonderful to be joined by
today but also for the wider families
including members of the zagari
ratcliffe family who live in my
constituency i pay huge tribute to all
involved including of course my right
honourable friend and
honourable members who sit opposite
who've done such a tremendous job on
behalf of their constituents there will
be many lessons wrongly drawn from this
sad episode can i suggest my writing or
friend there's one lesson that could be
correctly drawn the fact that these
people were imprisoned in iran is the
fault of the iranian regime the
difficulties that the uk government has
faced repaying the ims loan are also the
fault of the iranian regime because they
largely relate to sanctions imposed upon
the iranian regime is this a lesson of
wider application in the world today
that if you find yourself subject to
international sanctions you will find
there are long and expensive
consequences
well my honourable friend makes a very
effective point about sanctions and what
we are seeing today in russia
uh the fact that the
government of russia is struggling
to finance uh its appalling war in
ukraine uh the fact that people are
struggling to
secure the goods and services that they
had become used to in the country has
been returned to something akin to the
soviet era shows that sanctions do work
and are effective drew hendrick
thank you mr speaker the joy and relief
will be felt by all of our constituents
who've been fully behind richard
ratcliffe and the families in terms of
getting their loved ones home
given that there has been a solution in
plain sight which the foreign secretary
has been able to use today does she
agree that should never again take two
hunger strikes the terms of three prime
ministers five foreign secretaries and
five ministers for the middle east to
get a solution for people in this
situation in the future
this is an issue that the foreign office
has been working on tirelessly
for many years
given there was a new government in
tehran
last summer
given there was an opportunity to reset
the relationship and to start working on
these issues afresh we took that
opportunity but we were only able to do
it because of the tireless work of
foreign office officials it is not easy
as my right honourable friend pointed
out to be able to pay the ims debt in
the current
scenario and we did find a way to do it
and i'm very pleased that we have
simon hall thank you mr speaker the
plaudits that my rational friend is
receiving today are richly deserved and
she and the other ministers and
officials deserve the warmer thoughts of
the house
she has said she can't go into all the
details about the humanitarian aid but
can she assure us that that would be
humanitarian aid which iran will spend
within country
because the definition of humanitarian
aid will change we know that mr putin is
calling for allies in the middle east to
help him in his humanitarian
work in the ukraine
and we need to make very certain that
those sums are not deployed in that
arena and whilst i got her attention
as she has a magic wand to solving very
long-standing problems can she now turn
her attentions to libya and redress for
those victims of ira terrorism from
libyan sponsored atrocities
i can assure
the uh honorable my honourable friend
that the definition of humanitarian aid
in this in this uh agreement is
certainly not uh the definition of
humanitarian aid that vladimir putin
would subscribe to
ely reeves thank you mr speaker and i
know the joy my constituents of lewisham
west and penj will be feeling at today's
news and i thank the foreign secretary
for her work i had the privilege of
meeting richard ratcliffe when he was on
hunger strike last winter his dignity
courage and resolve was humbling but i
recall his frustration over delay after
delay after delay
a mother and their child should never be
separated for all these years
the foreign secretary must ensure that
lessons aren't learned are learned so
that as she says this never happens
again and i'll be grateful for her
comments as to how she uh intends that
to happen
well we are all very very pleased that
the families are able to be reunited
in dealing with this issue and i've been
working on it since i became foreign
secretary in september
there are a lot of complexities and
there are difficulties in working
given
the sanctions regime
given the process that needs to be gone
through
and
hours and hours have been put into the
meetings the phone calls and getting
this right and right up until the last
minute
uh which came at one o'clock uh this
afternoon
you know it it's always been
touch and go so
i would just say to your lady that there
is an incredible amount of complexity uh
lying underneath in terms of what we
have to do and what our counterpart
governments have to do
to be able to affect these types of
change but i'm
very clear that
we do have some excellent officials
who've really done the business on the
ground in tehran
can i congratulate my right honourable
friend and
uh both our writer friends for the work
they've done in delivering this in short
order after such a long period of
frustration and obviously those of our
honourable colleagues who have been
campaigning for this uh can i pay
tribute uh to richard radcliffe who
today must feel unalloyed joy
that the love that he has shown to his
wife has allowed him to campaign through
adversity to deliver this day and i
therefore pay tribute to him completely
can i also say however to my honourable
friend that as we look forward and
people are dying in the ukraine to fight
for freedom
we are learning a lesson and that lesson
surely has application here
it is that when states behave beyond the
rule of law
we need to act swiftly and immediately
isolate them with sanctions and this
therefore in the future
the unlawful taking of uh prisoners
uh in a case like this ever again
the west must unite the whole world must
unite in immediately bringing sanctions
against those countries such that the
pain they will feel outweighs any of the
gain they think they may receive
seriously well my my right honourable
friend is
absolutely correct and this is
why
it's important that the
west and the wider free world has
stepped up uh in the ukraine crisis for
too many years frankly we didn't do
enough
and blind eyes were turned to
some of these egregious practices that
is why as well as the work we are doing
together to impose sanctions on russia
for their appalling actions in ukraine
we're also working together on the issue
of unfair detention so that we protect
the rules-based system when we defend
freedom and democracy around the world
and this slot thank you mr speaker this
is very good news but it's not the end
of the matter even if the foreign
secretary won't discuss individual cases
should be aware that there are a number
of uk citizens of jewel nationals still
held in iran and some for good reason
will not be as well known as nazarene so
will she meet with the mps and the
families whose relatives are still
detained in iran and what leverage does
she think she will now have that the
debt has been paid
what is secretary well of course i will
continue to meet with families of
detained individuals and i will continue
to work
to get those people
released from on their detention
david
thank you mr speaker the foreign
secretaries to be rightly commended for
achieving this uh joyous outcome but
will she join with me in commending the
thousands of ordinary people across the
united kingdom who don't know
a
or richard or anusha personally but yet
have stood firmly with them throughout
all these years and have kept us mps
honest by relentlessly pursuing us to
raise the issue in parliament to engage
with richard in his
hunger strikes and other
efforts and doesn't it just show that it
is always worthwhile however a complex
issue for members of the public to
engage with an issue for a secretary
this issue has touched the hearts of the
british public and i know we've all seen
that as mps uh in our post pads and who
can fail to be moved by the courage and
tenacity shown by the families but also
the suffering uh that has been undergone
uh by those unfairly detained and those
who've been separated from them for so
many years and you know i think we're
seeing with the uh offers of the british
public to offer homes for ukrainian uh
refugees that
the british public are big-hearted and
we do want to see
uh our citizens thrive and we do want to
see these families reunited
christine thank you madame deputy
speaker can i add my congratulations and
thanks to the foreign secretary her team
and particularly to my honourable
friends for their tireless campaign and
to mr radley who i've met on several
occasions in difficult circumstances
moving beyond today's announcements we
know that iran is a difficult and
multi-layered country to do dealings
with is there any hope of perhaps it's
moving towards
a more
accommodating arrangement with the rest
of the world and that perhaps we might
be able to not normalize but
improve relations slightly in the long
run
foreign secretary well in resolving the
issue of the ims debt and in resolving
the issue
of these particular unfairly detained
detainees
we have
dealt with two of the major
issues facing uh the uk and iran of
course we have
very large concerns about iran acquiring
a nuclear weapon and that is what we are
currently working on with partners is to
prevent that happening because we know
when a
nuclear state
poses a danger to the world where that
can lead
so that is really our focus working with
partners and directly engaging of course
with the iranian government as i have
drummond
thank you very much melvin deputy
speaker and can i also add my thanks to
the foreign secretary and also her
predecessors who've been badgered by
many years but particularly the last six
years and i'm so pleased that she put it
as one of her priorities but can i also
pay tribute to the families of anusha
and nazanin especially richard ratcliffe
and the family who i met outside of the
fcdo during the hunger strike um because
they can we can my honourable friend um
join with me in thanking the british
negotiating team in tehran who've been
working so hard to get the three british
systems released and can i ask her does
she think that this is the beginning of
a new relationship with iran for the
long term
foreign secretary
she is right to pay tribute to the
family to richard ratcliffe to all the
work he's done campaigning but also to
our negotiating team who have worked day
in day out including in tehran and also
in muscat
to get to get this done
and that that has been
really important as the question of the
future
of iran
that is a choice for the iranian
government
now
we don't want to see iran acquire a
nuclear weapon
we do want to
see a world in which iran pays a more
positive role and of course we will work
to encourage a more positive trajectory
alice carmichael thank you mister madame
dick please speak a bigger pardon
can i thank and welcome the words of the
foreign secretary in relation to
arbitrary detention i think that does
come to the heart of it of course
arbitrary detention is not just the sole
preserve of iran
it is also a common practice in the
kingdom of saudi arabia where it is
reported there were a further three
executions today while the prime
minister was in country
can the foreign secretary give me some
assurance
that we shall pursue the issue of
arbitrary detention and other human
rights abuses with equal vigor wherever
we find them
foreign secretary we approach our
relations with all countries without
fear or favor
and we are prepared to be honest uh with
countries about human rights practices
that is exactly what the prime minister
has been doing on his visit but it is
important that we do engage saudi arabia
we have a major issue as everybody in
this house knows with a very aggressive
russia that has threatened
european indeed global security and we
need to work with other countries to
find alternative sources of oil and gas
and it is important that we deal with
everybody
thank you madam deputy speaker today is
of course a day of uh celebration albeit
tempered by the recollection of the
suffering that's been endured by nazi
and their families for a long period of
time
some people may be concerned at the
parallel payment of almost 400 million
so can my right honourable friend
reassure the house that this is money
that was legitimately owed to iran and
nobody should be under any
misapprehension that this government
would pay ransoms for people who are
illegally detained anywhere in the world
foreign secretary my honorable friend is
right we've always been clear that this
is legitimately
owed money that the uk should be paying
due to the complexity that has been a
difficult issue but we have been
we have been challenging in the way
we've been looking at the ways we can
pay that money ensuring of course that
it is spent on humanitarian purposes
that's been absolutely critical we have
found a solution to resolve that issue
wayne david
could i say like other members in the
house i'm truly delighted at the release
of an asho and nazini and could i also
pay tribute to richard who has been a a
tower of strength in this whole
unfortunate saga
could i also congratulate to the uh the
following secretary on her role and her
as she says creative civil servants who
found a way to repay this historic loan
as we often say whether is a will there
is a way and that has certainly been
proven to be the case but could i ask
her about the the role of the government
of oman i understand from her
but the the government of oman has been
playing a very positive vote but is it
the case but the role was such about the
money was actually transferred to iran
via the oman central bank
our amani friends have been extremely
helpful
working with us
to help transport
the detainees between
tehran
and
the united kingdom but also working with
us on some of the practical arrangements
around the detainees and working closely
with the iranian government we've also
had of course direct contact with the
iranian government too but it has been a
truly successful partnership in helping
this happen
scott benton thank you madame deputy
speaker may i congratulate the foreign
secretary on her work to secure the safe
release and return of nazazi
iran's malign influence continues to
remain a threat to british interests in
the middle east and indeed to those of
our allies most notably israel what
steps is a government taking to ensure
that any new agreement on iran's nuclear
weapon programme prevents them from
acquiring nuclear weapons foreign
secretary
it is correct that we have
very strong concerns about the ability
of iran
to acquire a nuclear weapon that is why
we've been working so closely uh with
our allies through the jcpoa to get a
new deal
uh to stop that acquisition it is
vitally important we do want iran to
take a different path a better path and
that comes with a combination
in my view of being absolutely clear
about what the penalties are namely the
sanctions but also having a positive
choice
that iran can make about its future
chris bryant thank you madam speaker i
warmly commend the foreign secretary and
all her team ministerial and and
officials on on this result apricity
means the feeling of the sun on your
face in winter and i'm sure that for
gabriella and for richard today is a day
of apricity sun on their face in a time
of winter
however
authoritarian regimes such as iran and
russia do two things very similarly they
do um arbitrary detention that she's
already spoken about but they also pump
their propaganda around the world
through state-funded broadcasters in
iran's case that is press tv thank
goodness it's not got a license here
anymore and i personally think that
anybody who's taken money from press tv
should be giving it back but shouldn't
exactly the same apply to
russia today isn't it time it was closed
down so we stopped hearing the
propaganda from russia about ukraine and
shouldn't everybody who's taken money
from them give it back or give it to
ukrainian refugee support
all right secretary
well the honourable gentleman is
absolutely right about state-funded
propaganda
and the fact that we don't see a free
media in many parts of the world and in
fact in some cases social media is
breaking that up and we've seen some of
that in russia although it's now being
cracked down on this is one of the
reasons that the government has
established the information unit to help
give the russian people the truth about
what's happening in their own country i
know my right-hand friend the culture
secretary is looking at precisely the
issue the honourable gentleman talks
about and i'm sure she'll be listening
very carefully to his question today
thank you madam deputy speaker and this
is the most joyous of days for this
house and the country and for a family
who have missed nazanin zagari radcliffe
a wife a mum a daughter and a
sister-in-law and in newport west this
case is personal because richard
reckless sister rebecca jones is a
constituent of mine and i've watched in
awe as she fought to get nazanin home
alongside the rest of the family and i
say to the minister for all the joy
today a case like this must never happen
again so will the secretary of state
ensure lessons are learned so no other
family has to go through such a dreadful
separation from a loved one in the
future
well i congratulate her constituent on
the work she's done to campaign for
nazanin's release and she is right we
cannot let this happen again and this
needs to be about what we do as the
united kingdom but also
how we work with our international
allies to
make sure there are not incentives in
place for these regimes to carry out
arbitrary detention
washington dr hughes thank you madam
deputy speakers right and proper that
the house congratulate the foreign
secretary and the ministerial team on
delivering on real diplomatic action
it's great to see
and also to the honourable members for
hampstead and kelburn and lush from east
a job well done for being parliamentary
representatives it's a great honour to
sit in any parliament and that's the job
of an mp and of course to the families
who are watching i was interested to
hear the foreign secretary talk about
arbitrary detention
and how we can work with other countries
to ensure that not only
dual nationals or tri-nationals but full
uk nationals are not arbitrarily
detained no matter their friendships
with countries and follow to i think was
the member for hammersmith who's no
longer in their place and the foreign
secretary said that they would meeting
with families who are detained and that
spirit of collaboration and working
together i wonder therefore would the
foreign secretary consider meeting with
me
and the family of jagdhar singh joe how
to understand the issue of arbitrary
detention
for other states it would be a most
welcome deliberation for the future
as i've said to the honourable gentleman
i have raised uh this specific case but
i would be happy to meet him to discuss
it further
mikey thank you thank you
speaker the american academic margaret
mead famously said never doubt that a
small group of thoughtful committed
citizens can change the world
nothing else in history ever has done so
well done to the foreign secretary her
minister the department and to my
friends from lewisham east and uh
hampstead and kilburn their work in this
has been indefatigable
i don't want to strike a discordant note
madam deputy speaker but the members for
the shadow foreign secretary the chair
of the foreign affairs select committee
the members for leeds and antrim have
alluded to this deal i think all of us
in parliament will be happier if there
was some briefing if there was some
scrutiny if it's done on privy council
terms even
foreign secretary
well i i hear what the honourable
gentleman says we do have an arrangement
and this was part of the very careful
negotiations that have taken place over
the last six months that this deal
would be kept confidential we do have
the humanitarian assurances on the ims
front i will see what i can do
within the bounds of that but i i do
have to say to your gentleman the united
kingdom is a country that keeps its word
we have made a made our word to keep
this confidential
last question margaret ferriero this is
a good day madam deputy speaker uh the
release of nazarene and anushay is
extremely welcome news and i thank the
foreign secretary and to officials and i
pay tribute to the families for their
bravery courage and resilience i didn't
want to have to see richard go on a
third hunger strike so given the length
of time they were detained and the other
dual nationals continue to be detained
in iran can she set out how she will
ensure that lessons are learned by the
government from these cases including in
relation to the provision of consular
services for uk nationals and their
families more generally
foreign
well i think i think the honourable lady
i think we've seen some very good
consular services in the in these cases
in other cases i think the lesson tv
learnt is this broader lesson about
arbitrary detention and how do we work
with our allies and partners to stop it
and i will
up the date the house on the progress of
this arbitrary detention work that we
are undertaking with the canadians we
first discussed it
back in november in fact at the uh nato
foreign ministers summit uh we discussed
it again at the g7 meeting and we are
making some real progress on this so i'd
be very happy to have further
discussions in due course
i do thank the um foreign secretary
for her uh statement
and we now move on to
our point of order angela rainer
thank you madam deputy speaker earlier
today i asked the deputy prime minister
whether the prime minister had ever
asked anyone to urge the security
services to reverse reconsider or
withdraw their assessment of lord
lebedev of hampton and siberia he
replied that the suggestion was sheer
nonsense but this afternoon the prime
minister's former chief adviser has
stated in writing that the prime
minister was told the intelligence
services had serious reservations but
cut a deal to provide the commission
with a sanitized version of the advice
the ministerial code requires ministers
to correct the record if they have
inadvertently misled the house as the
former downing street chief of staff has
alleged so can the madam deputy speaker
tell me if she has had any notice from
the deputy prime minister that he tends
to come to the house to correct the
record and if not can she advise me on
how the house can get the truth of this
very serious issue
well i'm
grateful to the uh right of a lady
for her point of order and for giving me
notice of it
as she will know
um the speaker is not responsible for
ministerial answers she is correct quite
correct that the ministerial code
requires ministers to correct any
inadvertent errors
the government ventures and i'm looking
to the
here
and to the ministers
will have heard her comments
and if an error has been made in this
instance
i hope it will be corrected
speedily
um of course the
minister
may take the view that there is no
inaccuracy um and i'm sure the right
honourable lady will find ways to pursue
the matter
in any event i'm quite certain of that
thank you
um we now come to the scottish national
party motion on increases in the cost of
living and i call stephen flynn to move
the motion
thank you very much madam deputies
because there's a phrase that was said
to me many many years ago and it's one
that stuck with me and one that i
believe is true to the debate that we
are about to have here today in relation
to the cost of living crisis and that's
the
poverty is a punishment for a crime that
he didn't even commit
and for
so many people at this moment people in
aberdeen and scotland are right across
this united kingdom there's a there's a
real feeling of helplessness of
hopelessness and of powerlessness that
the
situation that's in front of them their
food prices are soaring their fuel
prices
are soaring their energy prices
are soaring their children's clothes the
prices
are all soaring no matter which way they
turn they cannot escape the reality of
the the situation that's in front of
them the grim reality
of the situation
that's
in front of them and this cuts across
all swathes of society just yesterday
the dispatch box the chancellor was
extolling the virtues of the fact that
employment figures are up and good i
believe that everyone irrespective of
political party would would welcome that
of course we we can and we should
welcome that but what he didn't do
yesterday was address the fact that
people who are
in work that their energy prices will be
some 14 times
what their pay rises
may be he didn't address that i thought
he didn't even acknowledge
that that was a fact
beyond that he didn't address the fact
that if you're not in work and you're
reliant upon the state to provide social
security to you in order that you can
get by on a day-to-day basis he didn't
reflect or apologize for the fact that
just a matter of months ago he took some
20 pounds out of the pockets of those on
universal
credit
i'm more than happy to be on that point
i thank my effort for
giving way but when it comes to
deductions from the state
it's not just the 20 pound uplift it's
the fact that we have hundreds of
thousands of people across these islands
who every month gets 60 pounds taken off
them for for dwp deductions some of them
advances and some of them uh so-called
tax credit overpayments
absolutely my honourable friend is a
deputy champion for these causes and
makes his point extremely well and it
would be remiss of the government not to
listen to him on these points
and he is right to touch upon that as
indeed we all are right to touch upon
the cost of living crisis because it is
a crisis as a crisis for households up
and down the country
and what we need from the government in
a time of crisis is a response
we need them to take action to
improve people's lives to protect them
to insulate them from what is coming
down the road and sadly they have been
completely lacking in that regard and
i'm sure even in the hearts of hearts
many of the conservative backbenchers
although there is just a few in here
today would recognize the fact that the
government can and must
go further because all we've seen this
stage at this juncture despite the fact
that we know we've seen the energy price
cap increase exponentially and we know
that by the autumn it could well reach
around 3000 pounds per year all we've
seen is a 150 quid
towards a council tax revenue
yes of course i will
i'm grateful to the honourable for
giving away because it's absolutely
right of course to draw attention to the
question of the price cap but even
before that
consumers right across the country are
facing massive increases in the standing
charges
something for which there should be no
link to the cost of energy but it is
reported in fact that this is because
we are having to fund the supplier of
last resort as a consequence of the
failure of the small energy companies
does it does the honorable gentleman
share my sense that it is wrong to
expect consumers to pick up the tab for
what is essentially irregulatory failure
i i welcome the intervention from our
girlfriend and he's absolutely right and
the energy minister is sitting there and
i'm sure he'll take the opportunity to
address those remarks if he gets
opportunity to come to the dispatch box
later as i see he will be but it's not
just in terms of the money towards the
council tax we bet this the government
has put forward of course they've gone
so much further they have given people a
buy back loan in relation to their
energy bills pay by now pay later that's
that's the best that they can do in this
time
of crisis and of course that was
predicated
on the basis that energy prices would
reduce over time but the situation has
changed and there are of course many
experts and analysts who suggest that
that's not going to happen
anymore so the government need to get
real on this matter and they need
i'll give way now i'll give you that
very grateful marble friend for giving
ways making a point about energy price
increases of course
those energy price increases are going
to be devastating for many families
but for people living in off gas grid
areas they're going to be absolutely
crucified by the price increases because
they have to rely on bottled gas oil or
wood all of which are going up in price
and of course they're using more of that
expensive energy
at these times does my honorable friend
agree that action needs to be taken now
by this government to adopt regulation
for people who live off the gas grid so
they can be treated more fairly before
there's a crisis for rural
communities absolutely i couldn't agree
more wholeheartedly with my honourable
friend in that regard he makes an
extremely important point i know it's
one he's been making for many months now
and it's time that the government
listened and took action in that regard
and i'll of course give way to the
honorable displacement for giving away
so would he and his party now agree that
we need to get a lot more gas and oil
out of the north sea
so that that would generate tax revenue
that the treasury could use to ease the
squeeze instead of paying these huge
sums of money to qatar and russia for
lng
it's an interesting point that the
honourable
member makes of course he'll be
cognizant of the fact that when the oil
and gas comes out of the ground that is
of course in the hands of multinational
companies now do we want to be in a
situation where that gas is benefiting
us here rather than those abroad
absolutely should we be importing from
russia absolutely not and the government
have been right to take action in
relation to that but what i want to see
from his government and what he should
want to see from his government is a
terrible charging of investment in
renewables when are they going to come
forward with their energy security
strategy i've heard talk about it in the
paper but there's been no clarity
whatsoever and i will come back to that
point later on in my speech i'll kill
soggy again most of my constituents
still have gas spoilers and so
renewables will work one day but the
immediate crisis is we're short of gas
do we have our own or do we have foreign
gas if we have our own we get tax
revenue
it's interesting to know that we're
short of gas when i hear the opposite
coming from the minister on a very
regular basis that is that is the
important point in relation to us they
can they can try to
to disagree with their own government in
relation to these matters but in real
terms we are self-sufficient scotland is
self-sufficient when it comes to soil
and gas but we can and we must go so
much further on our renewables and if he
wants to hang around you can hear me
speak about that in due course
yes why not i'm very grateful for him
for generously giving away a further
time isn't it the case that
scotland who's a net exporter of energy
some i think around 153 of our needs
over the course of a
a year would have been able to do much
much more if this government hadn't
stood in the face of more root cheap and
reliable and green renewable energy by
by standing against in the contracts for
difference
allowing solar and wind and onshore wind
power for many many years we could have
been much further ahead so is there is
it not the case it's now their
responsibility to help people with a
costly living crisis that's being caused
by and by them and an energy increase at
the moment
yes perhaps
the reason we're in the situation that
we are at this moment in time is because
the government has not planned ahead
it's chosen to sit on a seat when it
should have been looking to the future
in terms of where we could go and i
certainly hope that the minister will
address that point in his summit
why not
my other friend knows that when the
price of oil goes up this increased tax
yield to the
uk exchequer when the price of a gallon
of petrol goes up there's extra duty for
the uk exchequer and when the price goes
up across the board on domestic bills
there's additional vat to the uk
exchequer does he not find it passing
strange that they touring back benches
aren't calling for this additional tax
yield the uk government already have
to reduce the cost of domestic bills
absolutely and as as i understand it in
relation to oil and gas in particular
that at this moment in time is in excess
of three billion pounds at the treasury
and believes that it's going to be taken
in that every single pound
and penny of that three billion pounds
should be directed towards providing
support to family